sauver les acquis sont sortis de leurs
studios aujourd'hui pour elle et vivre
l'ambiance d'un huis clos alors on est à
l'intérieur de la grande salle du vécu
aujourd'hui prendre connaissance des
dossiers par les rencontrer des gens
aussi alors il ya là un avis et
messieurs sont avec moi allons les trois
agents alors oui eu beaucoup de
discussions aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
aux âges que vous a dit votre expérience
au niveau rapidement au départ de ce
budget il ya des bonnes nouvelles dans
le budget alors on voit que la coalition
avenir québec a beaucoup tapé sur table
et sur l'économie établi sur l'éducation
la santé et même l'immigration julie on
se demandait cet après-midi langue est
l'arabe des sous pour justement ce
ministère qui fait l'objet de beaucoup
de discussions depuis le début de
l'année 42 % d'augmentation
c'est un monde oui c'est le grand
gagnant du budget on peut regarder aussi
du côté de l'éducation qui était la
priorité de la coalition a marqué bec
encore là des investissements et des
investissements en santé
la question maintenant quand je
surveillais la prévoyance est ce qu'on
sera capable d'assurer le coup c'est la
question que les oppositions pose est ce
qu on en fait beaucoup maintenant mais
est-ce qu'on serait capable de garder ce
rythme là alors ça ça va être là les
questions qu'on pourra poser
éventuellement pis il ya beaucoup de
programmes où on n'a pas beaucoup de
détails
c'est pour ça qu'on aime le plus mais
les ministres ont en venir nous
expliquer dans les prochaines semaines
dans le service après vente
qu'est ce qui va se passer mais pour
l'instant c'est méthode et bonne piste
mais pas encore assez de viande autour
de l'os pour nous permettre de nous
prononcer le nom de monsieur legault qui
était très très confiant ce matin que
monter les attentes
finalement est-ce que ce budget la
réponse est ce que c'est à la hauteur de
ce que dégagé d'après moi je peux dire
que ce qui est positif c'est que
monsieur legault pour accuser
il répétait qu on voit présenter un
budget fidèles à nos propres priorités
et c'est ce qui le fait il va pouvoir en
2000 et en 2009 toute l'année 2010 2020
dire ça en éducation soins à domicile
l'arjel
y'a pas de problème je suis à la même
place que marie ce qui m'écoeure selah
sue alors pour cette année sébastien
bazin 10 pour sa commune était comparé
regarder les associations pas 3000 ckoi
5000 mais quand même c'est significatif
pour le reconnaître les monsieur
monsieur legault et monsieur gérard font
un effort mais quand on suit le taux
croissance par la suite quand on suit le
taux de croissance des autres mozart
après beaucoup beaucoup de questions sur
comment on va juste faire comment
comment on va juste garder le cap sur
elle les services actuels eux paniquent
parce qu'on dit banide services actuels
ces peaux claires surtout qu'on a
beaucoup reproché du dernier
gouvernement de wordie et on faire
budget électoral mais la suite comment
ça va être long le jamais expliqué
monsieur legault a présenté son
gouvernement comme étant gouvernement de
changement mais ce changement là dans la
l'accélération sur le pauvre on l'a pas
entendu à ce que ça va venir dans les
annonces
enfin bon on verra on continue à dire on
verra ça se prononcer mais on n'a pas la
réponse à ces questions le 11 août bien
aujourd'hui qu'une ministre qui est très
très contente c'est marguerite doublé
oui est-ce que c'est très frappant dans
ce budget là la place qu'on accorde aux
aînés
de toutes sortes de façons avec toutes
sortes de services exactement mais on a
parlé des soins à domicile qui vont être
bonifiée sur je pense que l'absence des
élus à l'assemblée nationale souhaitant
réinvestissement là dessus on a les
maisons pour aînés une trentaine d'ici
la fin du mandat qui ont été annoncées
par contre au niveau des ch et celle
d'el arish la rénovation et la remise à
neuf de ces établissements ne sont pas à
l'honneur dans le budget qui a été
déposée donc c'est à dire que plusieurs
années malheureusement vont devoir
encore continuer peut-être vie dans des
situations qui pourraient être améliorés
j'espère qu'au cours des prochains
budgets il y aura une attention
particulière sur ce point là timmy sur
les animaleries ben évidemment ça c'est
pour madame
voilà pour pour marguerite blais c'est
la maison des aînés qui était comme son
projet faire cette espèce de nous les
actionnons son milieu de vie fait pour
elle
lieu de l'argent qui est mis en place
que beaucoup disaient ouais mais là
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
concrètement quand il veut le point
conomique on doit mieux rien alors
l'offre finalement on sent que vraiment
cette volonté lors de développer ce
nouveau modèle là mais effectivement il
va falloir s'occuper de ceux qui sont en
résidence dans les centres de soins
longue durée mais avec le transfert
aussi auquel on va devoir penser c'est
le métier à domicile où on met de
l'argent et les maisons des ennemis plus
les soins justement dans les centres de
soins longue durée dans ce spectre lol
comment les choses vont se faire
maintenant qu'on va mettre plus d'argent
dans les médias maintien des cerveaux
ministre aussi qu'on avait vu tout
sourire aujourd'hui c'est monsieur
robert je ministre de l'éducation
alors oui on sait sont vraiment son
cheval de bataille c'est de maternelle 4
en mettant de quatre ans il
vous aimez lire le budget vous aviez des
questions oui j'avais des questions
parce que mon fils rentre en première
année mais ça m'intéresse quand même l
année prochaine
ce devoir à la fois est-ce qu'on va
respecter l'engagement de cinq livres
est ce que le budget est là pour ça non
on va jusqu'à 3000 quand même c'est
significatif monsieur legault pourra
soulever à la période de questions peut
dire qu'on a promis aux investissements
en éducation comme en santé et voilà je
l'entends déjà dire ça l'argent est au
rendez-vous mais encore le canton suis
trop de croissance et pour l'éducation
et pour la santé c'est là pour cette
année et pour les anonymous est dans un
budget dans les prochaines années
et franchement je m'attendais ou pour
nous expliquer un peu plus comment on
voit sur ce pont levis a pu voici qu'on
a prévu parce que l'enjeu c'est pas
juste de capable de répondre aux
engagements qui tente de faire ce qu'on
fait avec un investissement qui est
significatif mais je vais pas le
minimiser mais faut toujours garder en
tête que la population même si on coupe
les migrations continue d'augmenter avec
les pressions sur le maintien de
services en sorte que ça va coûter plus
cher alors comment respecter avec juste
le maintien de panier de services
actuels tout en ajoutant des services
parce qu'on le dit qu'on a appris à des
besoins aussi là c'est le défi et c'est
monsieur dubé qui va nous
nous répond monsieur dubé peut-être
monsieur fatigue est bonne parce qu'on a
eu la chance d'échanger avec le ministre
de l'économie et lui dit on parce qu'il
faut effectivement faire croire que la
tap dont on veut toujours davantage
éclairé de la richesse avoir des
meilleurs salaires et tout ça parce que
si on veut donc plus grands revenus aux
niveaux un plus grand retour au niveau
des revenus autonomes
il faut être capable de générer 7 chez
cela et lundi on a différents enjeux
dont celui de la productivité et là
dessus on est d'accord il ya des chefs
encore qui ont été publiés cette semaine
qui prouve que nos entreprises doivent
réinvestir est là et avec investissement
québec on va mettre en place des
éléments pour aider aux
réinvestissements mais aussi aider à
l'émergence des nouvelles des nouvelles
entreprises et faciliter la vie des
entreprises mais sa facilité la vie des
entreprises c'est probablement le plus
grand défi kia parce que tu es le dit
chez uniqlo ça fait des années qu'on en
parle mais on l'a toujours pourvus alors
on a envie de voir justement comment tu
étais toujours seul commun on va être en
mesure de simplifier et de désinfection
qu'elles étaient bâties quand vous
écoutez c'est facile de dire qu'on veut
alléger la bureaucratie pour les
entreprises mais une fois qu'on est dans
une place on sait quand même que des
éléments de ce pourquoi ces règles-là
existe est bien cadré est intéressant
qui viendra bonifier aussi ce que marie
annoncé c'est qu'ils ont un clin d'oeil
ou si je pense à l'intelligence
artificielle dont vous comme étant une
solution pour assez justement
d'augmenter la productivité en
entreprise vous avez reconnecter avec
des gens nous avaient fréquenté par le
passé vous avez entendu des gens de
position aussi parce que vous nous
parler de ce qui se dégage de ce budget
qui méritent d'être mis en valeur il ya
des choses qui vont rendre effectivement
les gens contents mais on sait aussi que
l'opposition est plus c'est kyle en
essayant de trouver les bidons à wil et
se servant des occasions pouvoir dire où
on vous prend défaut ici avez vous déjà
vu entendu des choses drôles et s'élance
à certaines promesses s'étire dans le
temps alors il a vu notamment pour la
connexion aux vitesses légales on est
rendu à sept ans je pense dans les
discours de monsieur de monsieur
monsieur girard qui le nouveau ministre
des finances et puis j'ai vu aussi qu'au
niveau de l'environnement le transport
collectif et est le grand oublié c'est à
dire qu'on diminue les budgets pour le
transport collectif au cours des quatre
prochaines années alors qu on augmente
le pq i pour élargir évidemment le
réseau routier
on sent que la sensibilité de la caq à
l'égard de ce dossier pas à son meilleur
en fait certains vous diront que parce
que évidemment de chaque côté on s
on essaie de nous montrer les prismes
ans ferrat et là ce qu'on dit c'est que
plusieurs projets de transports
collectifs qui sont à l'étude et ça ça
parait pas encore dans le pq on va
falloir suivre les choses de manière
très serrée mais à des groupes ou six
qui sont ici ce qu'on appelle les
groupes socioéconomiques je parlais par
exemple avec les gens du secteur du
commerce de détail qui nous faisait
c'est intéressant de voir qu'on veut
maintenir les gens plus âgés sur le
marché du travail
ceci dit le programme qu'on met en place
actuellement fait en sorte que ça
s'applique à des entreprises qui ont une
masse salariale tellement important que
pour bien des commerces
ça sera pas possible c'est pas rentable
pour eux alors ça ça fait partie aussi
des choses qu'on découvre quand on est
ici parce que on voit les sensibilités
et lumière les limites de différents
programmes qui peuvent être intéressants
mais qui donne pas nécessairement le
plein potentiel dans cette nasse
certains seigneurs des discussions aussi
avec des gens vous avez déjà côtoyé pas
oui mais oui c'est sûr que j'ai eu des
discussions puis comme marie j'ai pu
rendre les différents groupes c'est
toujours les deux ans les gens sont cons
son rôle tant d'autres déçus dans la
colonne des déçus
on entend la fédération des infirmières
du québec déçus parce qu'on voit pas
comment on va étendre le projet ratio et
on sait que ça quel point cet enjeu là
on a beaucoup beaucoup parlé des
derniers dans la dernière année mais des
deux dernières années des sapins des
années quand même de revoir les ratios
le projet pilote tire à sa fin
on sent beaucoup avec 215 millions alors
pour moi c'est des gros chiffres
paraît-il que on n'est vraiment pas au
rendez vous pour pouvoir assurer
bon ça fait peur ça va faire partie des
douze pour madame beckham la seconde en
avant goût c'est un peu votre analyse à
chaud évidemment alors qu'on est encore
dans cet endroit on est encore plein
actuellement pour la sortie encore de la
famille sinon mal à quelques secondes on
va sortir dans quelques minutes
on va suivre aussi les réactions enfin
on va se retrouver lundi mais excellent
on dirait vraiment en profondeur puis on
analysera boire est-ce que ça pour cent
font 90 % sont 15% c'est quoi exactement
les bilans ce budget là merci et c'est
encore à voir mais à mes yeux